la bataille de france
pendant l'entre-deux-guerres les futurs
commandants des troupes blindées
allemandes menait une existence étrange
ces soldats professionnels et
respectable en était réduit à travailler
en secret le traité de versailles avait
totalement interdit l'emploi de blindés
pour l'armée allemande
mais avec l'aide de la russie soviétique
et l'assistance déguisé d'une petite
équipe d'ingénieurs spécialisés
utilisant de faux matériel agricole goût
derian et ses collègues tentaient de
suivre le rythme du développement de
l'armé blindée
en dépit de ces conditions difficiles
ils ont réussi à développer seuls
quelques innovations notables
il était conscient des avantages que les
chats pouvait apporter dans les conflits
futurs et ont développé de nouvelles
théories centrée sur l'emploi des
blindés théorie qui allait révolutionner
la manière de conduire une guerre en
dépit du problème d'avoir à convaincre
ses supérieurs des avantages donnés par
les tanks goût derian en particulier se
consacrer à sa mission secrète avec une
détermination forte grâce à quelques
démonstrations impressionnantes lors
d'exercices il finit par convaincre à la
fois l'état major allemand et adolf
hitler que les blindés pouvait gagner
les guerres futures
je me tiens ici au musée du blindé de
boeing tonnes devant un penseur qui a
été l'un des piliers de la force
blindées allemandes en 1939
c'est une version de commandement qui
est notablement plus haute que le panzer
un de base mais comme vous pouvez le
voir il est loin d'être le mastodonte de
la légende c'est une petite machine par
bien des aspects il n'est pas plus large
qu'une land rover moderne mais il y en
avait probablement 1500 service en 1939
et 1940 qu'il n'y avait pas d'autre
alternative
on ne peut nier qu'un char comme le
panzer 2 est un peu léger son canon de
20 mm ne pouvait pas vraiment faire peur
et son épaisseur de glandage était loin
d'être impressionnantes
c'est probablement une bonne
illustration que c'est plus souvent la
manière d'utiliser un char ou comment
l'armée blindée est utilisée
collectivement qui est plus important
que la véritable puissance de son canon
où l'épaisseur de son blindage le
résultat des efforts de goût derian et
que en 1935 les 1re division de panzers
sont créés chaque arme devait être
présente dans la panzer division health
pour en faire une petite armée presque
indépendant ces formations comprenait
une brigade blindée de 560 chars pour
fournir la puissance de feu principal
cette brigade était composé de deux
régiments de chars dont chacun était
divisée en deux bataillons deux
régiments d'infanterie motorisée
fournissait l'appui rapproché aux
blindés un bataillon de reconnaissance
fut ajoutée pour la recherche de
positions ennemies et l'estimation des
points faibles
un bataillon d'artillerie motorisé avec
48 cas n'ont fourni c'est le support
d'artillerie pour la défense contre les
tanks ennemis
un bataillon antichar fut aussi ajouté
et bien sûr la division disposer de ses
propres unités d'approvisionnement de
support logistique et l'entretien de
rien avait compris que les chars et les
armes blindés allaient être dans le
futur une force de frappe rapide et
puissante eca compagnie d'infanterie
d'artillerie et toutes les autres armes
en service il apporterait un punch
décisif
on peut revenir sur deux événements qui
se sont déroulés sur la plaine de
salisbury en 1928 1929 qui constituèrent
un véritable test pour l'emploi des
blindés ce qui s'est réellement passé
c'est qu'une unité connu comme forces
blindées expérimental a été créé et
cette force blindés étaient constitués
de bataillon de chars des chars légers
de reconnaissance des transports de
mitrailleuses d'infanterie de véhicules
blindés pour la reconnaissance de
l'artillerie autopropulsés de
techniciens d'entretien mobile avec
leurs camions
c'est même de soldats transporter avec
des half track l'ensemble était appuyée
par la royal air force à la fin vous
obteniez une petite armée terriblement
mobile disposant d'une puissance de feu
incroyable pendant ces exercices dans la
plaine il était opposé à une infanterie
conventionnelle à la cavalerie à une
division d'artillerie peau mobile bien
plus importante dans chaque opération
peu importe comment les arbitres trichet
et il trichait pour tenter de donner aux
armes traditionnelles un peu de soutien
au cours de chaque action isolée mais la
preuve était là et l'effet que ça eu
était impressionnant en angleterre un ou
deux vieux officiers mal embouché
commencèrent à se poser la question de
l'éventuel avenir des blindés ceux qui
en tirent les enseignements étaient les
allemands il avait pu voir qu'une force
très mobiles pouvaient être créées pas
seulement des chars seul vous avez
besoin du soutien de l'artillerie vous
avez besoin de garder l'infanterie à vos
côtés vous avez besoin que tous soient
mobiles et vous avez besoin d'un soutien
aérien immédiat dans death tout cas il
ne s'est armée d'un nouveau genre envoyé
contre une armée conventionnelle pouvait
la couper en deux comme un couteau dans
du beurre
les chars lourds devaient être utilisés
comme fer de lance pour véritablement
percé un trou dans les lignes ennemies
et les chars légers devaient être
utilisés sur les flancs pour les
protégés de l'infanterie et des tirs
d'artillerie et tous les autres chars
devaient être utilisés principalement
pour ouvrir la route à travers les
lignes ennemies et garder ce trop ouvert
et continuer d'avancer une réflexion
importante avait été menée pour le
développement de ce type de formation
la panzer division qui est un résultat
était une force bien équilibrée qui
pouvaient faire appel au soutien de tous
les autres composants pour atteindre ses
objectifs
le but de cette organisation lancé une
offensive rapide et profonde en
territoire ennemi et y maintenir la
confusion la peur et la panique au sein
de son commandement et de ses
communications
les relations étroites avec la luftwaffe
qui pouvait apporter encore plus de
puissance de feu quand le besoin s'en
faisait sentir représentait une
innovation importante la luftwaffe et
les division de panzers avait des liens
très étroits car la luftwaffe avec des
officiers de liaison au sol avec les
divisions blindées ce signifier qu'à
chaque fois qu'une division blindée se
retrouvait face à un problème quelconque
ou l'appui aérien pouvait être utile
tampon une liaison radio était établi
avec la luftwaffe ce qui permettait aux
tout cas et aux autres bombardiers
d'être appelés pour intervenir très vite
cette flexibilité et la rapidité de
l'appel au soutien aérien était vital
est constitué un des éléments clés de la
guerre éclair
l'entraînement donné aux nouveaux
combattants insistait sur la vitesse et
l'indépendance d'esprit
quand ces unités n'étaient pas tenus en
laisse elle devenait une arme
terriblement efficace que les ennemis ne
pouvait pas contenir
en pologne cette nouvelle force avait
tué la première opportunité de mettre en
pratique son entraînement
blitzkrieg
la campagne de pologne fut un triomphe
pour la wehrmacht et démontra le
potentiel des blindés lors d'une
bataille
cependant certains problèmes furent
rencontrer et cause parce que les
événements sont année un peu plus vite
qu hitler ne l'avait prévu il avait
fallu faire entrer ces engins en service
à redéployer le furent utilisés lors de
la campagne de pologne ou leur faiblesse
avait été vraiment visible il était
évident que ces machines devaient être
retirés été maintenu en service jusqu'en
1941 et même un peu plus tard car il
était simplement impossible non produire
en quantité suffisante pour être envoyés
sur le front dans le laps de temps le 10
mai 1940 la vague hitlérienne déferla à
l'ouest
cette fois les allemands allaient
affronter des armées modernes qui était
équipé de matériel équivalent si ce
n'est supérieur au leur
la ligne maginot qui s'étendaient le
long de la frontière est de la france
fut contourner quand les panzers
avancèrent par les ardennes en belgique
grâce à une planification précise la
surprise et quelques innovations aux et
les allemands rendirent ses
fortifications complètement inutile
une fois passée ils avancèrent vers la
côte il ne rencontrèrent pratiquement
rien pour les stopper ce qui s'était
avéré impossible pendant les quatre
années de la première guerre mondiale
avaient été accomplis en six semaines
l'importance du rôle des blindés dans la
guerre moderne venait d'être démontrée
les panzers
vous
les chars qui ont permis ces premières
victoires et écrit une nouvelle légende
militaires étaient quatre machines
allemandes
épaulé par deux types de blindés
construit par skoda en tchécoslovaquie
le panzer 1 et de prendre leurs deux
étaient principalement employé comme
véhicule de reconnaissance le panzer 1
avait un équipage de deux hommes un
conducteur et un chef de char et il
était armé de deux mitrailleuses de 7 92
mm tandis que le panzer de avait un
équipage de trois hommes étaient armés
d'un canon automatique de 20 mm le
panzer 3 et le panzer quatre étaient les
chats plus lourd avec un équipage de
cinq hommes un conducteur et un
mitrailleur dans la caisse un
mitrailleur le chef de char et un
approvisionneurs charger dans la
tourelle le panzer 3 et est
principalement utilisé comme chars de
combat 4 lui comme blindé de soutien
avec son canon de 75
ce canon avait le calibre minimum des
canons installé sur le char sherman
je prends mesure 4 a donc largement
influencé le développement des canons
des chars américains pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale
le premier des nouveaux chars allemands
était le petit panzer 1 il dérivait
détracteurs s'entoure elle développé en
secret entre les deux guerres il pesé un
peu moins de 6 tonnes et avait un
équipage de deux hommes et son armement
était constitué de mitrailleuses le
blindage principal de 13 mm de métal et
ses limites avait été montrée en pologne
ce véhicule fut utilisé intensivement
pendant la campagne à l'ouest le panzer
un été conçu comme une automitrailleuse
blindés ils ne constituaient pas une
grande menace pour les blindés ennemis
agit comme si comme vous le voyez ce
n'était pas un gros véhicule
je ne suis pas particulièrement grand et
j'arrive à sa hauteur il n'est pas très
blindés et donc fragile mais en 1939
c'était ce genre de véhicule auquel vous
deviez faire face en 1940 ce sont les
même engins qui ont déferlé sur la
france y ont pris une part importante
dans la guerre éclair à la base c'était
un véhicule d'entraînement utilisé pour
les différents conducteurs qui aurait
ensuite à conduire des chars plus gros
et plus lourd
il avait des moteurs ordinaire rien de
vraiment spécial
il n'était pas très rapide le panzer de
été conçu pour épauler le panzer 1 et
être un char disposant de capacité d'
attaques anti blindage
les premiers modèles pesé un peu moins
de huit tonnes
les modèles suivants ont vu leur poids
augmenter et dépasser 10 tonnes ce
véhicule avait un équipage de trois
hommes une mitrailleuse mg 34 et un
canon de 20 mm en est l armement le
blindage était de 13 mm pour le modèle à
et 30 mm pour le modèle h le panzer de
était un char fiable il avait une
vitesse de pointe de 55 km heure comme
le poseur 1
ce char était déjà dépassée même au
début de la guerre il n'était pas assez
blindé le canon de 20 mm et est
inefficace contre les charrs alliés
le panzer 2 devait être utilisée comme
véhicule de reconnaissance mais s'est
retrouvé au coeur du combat
jouant le rôle de chars de combat et le
panzer ii est équipé d'une arme
automatique de 20 mm à la cadence de tir
très régulier à côté de lui une
mitrailleuse allemande typique la mg 34
à la cadence de tir très rapide
l'autre chose que je veux montrer que je
penserais délatrice et que les charrs
helmand été construit par soudage et
c'est une différence qu'il faut
souligner car cela signifie que le char
est plus solide qu'il n'a pas besoin
d'un châssis l'alourdissant et qu'en
plus cela le rend bien plus étanche le
panzer 3 été classée parmi les chars
moyen par les allemands mais aux
standards de l'époque il était quand
même bien léger le poids du panzer 3
utilisé lors de la campagne à l'ouest
autour de 20 tonnes
il avait un équipage de cinq hommes tous
les panzers trois engagés au combat en
1940 avait un canon de 37 millimètres
comme armement principal il était épaulé
par 3 mg 34,2 était placée dans la
tourelle de chaque côté du canon et la
troisième était à l'avant du véhicule
ce char avait 30 mm de blindage une
vitesse maximum de 40 km heure cependant
le principal problème venait du canon de
37 mm il était peu compétitifs face au
blindage plus lourd des engins allier la
décision d'équiper les premiers panzer 3
avec ce canon de 37 millimètres avaient
inquiété goût derian qui voulait que les
panzers 3 soit équipé d'une arme d'au
moins 50 mm pour que les obus est une
vraie chance de percer l'épais blindage
des chars anglais et français
les modèles plus tardif reçurent le
canot principal de 50 mm mais arrivèrent
trop tard pour être utilisés pendant les
combats à l'ouest le mark iii est sorti
parce que les améliorations que l'on
allait apporter dans les panzers 4
ultérieurement avait pris plus de temps
que prévu
ils ont fabriqué se prend deux heures
trois qui était une version plus petite
et qui s'est parfaitement comportée en
france
bien qu'inférieures aux chars anglais ou
français en plus du panzer 3 les
divisions blindées allemandes comportait
des chars de soutien d'enfants pris ses
premiers penseurs 4 avait un canot
principal de 75 mm à canon court est
faible vitesse initiale
il était épaulé par deux mitrailleuses
mg 34 l'une était situé dans la tourelle
et l'autre à l'avant du châssis
le blindage varier de 15 à 30 mm
la vitesse était la même que celle du
panzer 3 soit 40 km heure ce blindé
était correctement conçus bien que les
versions en service à ce moment de la
guerre était équipé du canon à faible
vitesse initiale elle 24 conçu seulement
pour tirer des obus explosifs et qui
manquait d'une véritable puissance
d'impact indispensable pour les combats
entre chars une fois améliorée il devint
le principal chars de bataille des
forces allemandes pour le reste de la
guerre c'est une des premières versions
du panzer 4 qui fut le char de soutien
d'infanterie utilisées par les forces
allemandes au début de la guerre jusqu'à
la campagne dans le désert
on peut dire que c'est une des premières
versions avec son poste de commandement
a grandi sur le dessus qui ressemble
presque à une poubelle qui aurait été
collées sur le chat comme vous pouvez le
voir ce n'est pas une innovation
particulièrement bonne car au combat
c'était des cibles de choix
il était fréquemment touchée par
l'artillerie ennemie ils ont commencé à
les retirer vers 1940 est ici vers
l'avant nous voyons le canon de 75 mm de
support d'infanterie qui n'était pas un
canon à haute vitesse initiale et qui ne
donnait pas tout la puissance antichar
dont ils avaient besoin lors de la
campagne de russie
en revanche pour les premiers combats
dans le désert c'était assez bien adapté
nous pouvons voir ici la finesse du
blindage qui à cette époque de la guerre
était de 48 m et qui allait devenir de
plus en plus épais au fur et à mesure de
l'évolution des combats
l'une des manières d'améliorer les
promeneurs 4 était d'ajouter des plaques
de métal supplémentaires sur l'avant de
la tourelle ce qui donnait une
résistance supplémentaire ainsi que du
blindage plat sur l'avant ici et comme
le char a été amélioré au long de la
guerre ils ont réalisé que ce dont ils
avaient besoin était un blindage incliné
pour que les obus ricoche contre le
véhicule
il s'agissait là d'une mauvaise
conception du véhicule et ses leçons
avait besoin d'être apprises et
assimilés lorsque les allemands 1 exr la
région de la bohême et de la moravie au
début de 1939 il prit possession de l'
usine de construction des chars de
combat tchèque
ces machines furent incorporés dans les
unités allemandes
il en existait deux types le 35t pesait
10 tonnes et avait un équipage de quatre
hommes
il était armé d'un canon de 37 mm très
efficace ainsi que de deux mitrailleuses
de 7,92 sa protection était de 35 mm
d'épaisseur assez bien adapté pour un
char léger et son moteur permettait
d'atteindre 40 km/heure en pointe
le second charte chèques utilisés par
les allemands et est le 38 t il peser
moins que le 35t avec 9 tonnes et demi
et il avait aussi un équipage de quatre
hommes
son armement et est constitué d'un canon
de 37 et deux mitrailleuses
le blindage était de 30 mm il avait une
vitesse de pointe de 42 km heure à la
différence du 35t cette machine était
réputé pour sa fiabilité et la facilité
de son entretien
ces deux chars légers ont été un renfort
tout à fait valable pour les chars
utilisé par les allemands on a même dit
que sans ces deux machines
les allemands auraient été incapable de
conduire leur offensive à l'ouest de 35
t en 1940 était un vieux char il fut
retirée du service après 1940 est le 38
t était une vraie réussite et fut
utilisée avec beaucoup de succès pendant
la bataille de france il était capable
d'affronter les mathilda est un grand
nombre de véhicules français car il
était aussi rapide aussi bien blindé et
son canon d'une taille respectable lui
permettait d' engager les matinées
c'était un bon choix et il fut utilisé
longtemps pendant la guerre il servirait
plus tard de base de développement pour
d'autres véhicules blindés comme des
canons automoteurs et les véhicules anti
char
le 35 t il fut fournie à la 6ème peur
division est le 38 t constituait
l'essentiel des 7e et 8e pender division
pendant la bataille de france six chars
tchèque furent engagés au coeur du
combat car la 7e porteur d'une vision
constitue l essentiel de la force de
frappe de la bataille à venir
le 38 t resta en service en allemagne
tout au long de la guerre sous diverses
formes et finit par servir de base à
l'excellent et zaire antichar dans la
guerre éclair de 1940 la 7e division
était celle de romell presque
entièrement équipée de 38 et de 35 t de
fait il n'y avait presque 400 chars
tchèque impliqués dans cette bataille
le 38 t avait été proposé à l'armée
anglaise et avait été testé en
angleterre à chelsea de 1938 à 1939
les anglais lui avait trouvé bien des
lacunes mais les allemands en était
parfaitement satisfait et il remporta
beaucoup de succès pendant la bataille
de france de 1940
les chars britannique
sans avoir à subir les restrictions dont
les allemands avaient été victimes les
principaux alliés france et angleterre
avait aussi engagé le développement de
leur armement pendant les années 20 et
il avait cependant pris les voies
différentes les autres nations majeures
n'avait pas reconnu le plein potentiel
des chars et donc l'innovation dans ce
domaine avaient été assez limitées
la france avait relégué les chars au
rôle d'armes de soutien d'infanterie les
anglais avaient vu le potentiel de ces
nouvelles machines mais était en train
de développer de nouveaux concepts
c'est un chat reconnu comme le char
léger marque 6 b et ce n'est rien
d'autre qu'un véhicule de reconnaissance
on peut dire que c'est une voiture
blindée sur des chenilles re l'épaisseur
du blindage et minimal et un canon
antichar moyen peut le traverser
facilement
son rôle est de se déplacer discrètement
dans la campagne rapidement et de
rassembler le maximum d'informations
mais ce n'est pas à strictement parler
une machine de combat
basiquement un petit char léger très
similaire aux panthers 1 en termes de
performance et de capacité
certains pensent que la meilleure des
choses concernant ce véhicule c'est de
l'avoir abandonnée sur les plages de
dunkerque
c'était un engin déjà dépassé le
mathilde un mk1 fut conçu comme un char
léger et ils poseront stone il avait un
équipage de deux hommes son armement
principal était une mitrailleuse vickers
comme le panzer 1
ce char était un peu plus qu une
automitrailleuse blindés cependant à la
différence du panzer un ce véhicule
avait une protection blindé de 60 mm
d'épaisseur
c'était le double de l'épaisseur du
meilleur char allemand de l'époque il
avait une vitesse maximum de 15 km heure
les limites de ce char furent révélés
par la campagne de france bien que son
équipage fut bien protégés ils ne
constituaient pas une menace pour les
équipages déterminer des blindés
allemands
latourelle avec un seul homme était
sérieusement pénalisante plus de 140
furent envoyés en france et tous furent
perdus dans la bataille des exemples
c'est un exemple de chars construits
pour correspondre à un prix
fut fixé à 8 heures sam strong en 1936
l'ingénieur avait quinze mille livres à
dépenser
il était construit comme un char bon
marché et avec le seul impératif d'avoir
un blindage assez épais pour résister à
n'importe quelle arme antichar l'idée
était d'avoir un char d'infanterie dans
l'idéologie britannique un char
d'infanterie était un char qui se
déplaçait lentement que l'infanterie
pouvait suivre quand elle se lançait à
l'assaut contre une position et ne
parlons pas de cross-country à grande
vitesse nous parlons de se déplacer
lentement ce qui attirait un maximum de
tirs ennemis d'où la nécessité d'être
invulnérable aux balles et d'être juste
là pour conduire l'infanterie jusqu'à
son objectif donc c'est bien si l'ennemi
est préparé à jouer ce jeu et si nos
chars sont installés dans de bonnes
positions défensives pour leur permettre
d'attaquer ok mais s'ils sont utilisés
en pleine campagne avec des blindés
ennemis autour ils seront mis en pièces
ce fut la situation en france où les
allemands en mouvement tout le temps ne
restez jamais en place ce n'attendait
pas d'être attaquée empêchant que ces
chars puisse servir à quoi que ce soit
le matilda 2 fut conçue pour permettre
l'installation d'une tourelle avec deux
hommes il arriva après qu'on ait réalisé
que le mathilde 1 ne pouvait pas
répondre aux exigences le matilda de
peser 27 tonnes et avait un équipage de
quatre hommes
il avait un canon dit de deux livres et
une mitrailleuse vickers
il était très bien protégé avec une
épaisseur de blindage de 78 mm sa
vitesse était au maximum de 24 km heure
il est probablement le plus connu des
chars anglais de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
ce char avait de bonnes performances est
resté en service pendant toute la guerre
sur tous les fronts nesta ce char et le
mieux connu des deux matilda qui
remplaçait les petits chars d'infanterie
marque un but
nous voulions un char qui pourraient
soutenir l'infanterie en roulant
lentement et être résistant au feu
ennemi cette raison son blindage
frontale était de 81 mm d'épaisseur ce
qui était signalé comme personne n'avait
jamais construit un char avec un
blindage aussi épais donc il avait de
bonnes chances de survie sur les champs
de bataille
il était aussi équipé du canot anglais 2
livre j'étais déjà considéré comme l'un
des meilleurs canons antichars dumont en
1940 il est intéressant de s'interroger
sur l'opportunité d'utiliser un canon
antichar sur un blindé
utilisé principalement un support de
troupes beaucoup de gens se posent la
question et il pense que les howitzer
tirant des obus explosifs auraient été
bien plus utile pour le type de combat
qu'on s'attendait à rencontrer la
réponse à cet argument était qu'en
équipe à un char avec un canon antichar
c'était non seulement pour appuyer
l'infanterie pendant ses déplacements
vers ses objectifs mais aussi pour
stopper les contre attaques des chars
ennemis ce qui était assez logique
le matilda mark 1 était un char
d'infanterie basique avec seulement une
mitrailleuse vickers comme armement
principal mais le plus impressionnant
était son blindage de 60 mm très
impressionnant pour l'époque
tim hill mathilde un mark ii était un
char encore mieux protégés avec 80 mm de
protection mais toujours armé seulement
d'un canon de deux livres n'est qu'ils
ne pouvaient tirer que des obus
perforant pas vraiment impressionnant
pour de l'appui d'infanterie cependant
en raison de son niveau de protection et
de blindages les deux types de matilda
donnait du fil à retordre à n'importe
quel canons antichars de l'époque qui
avait du mal à pénétrer leur blindage ce
qui signifiait que les matilda en 1940
pouvait combattre avec une invincibilité
relative contre les premières lignes de
défense où se tenait les canons
antichars
tu as passé chez les anglais utilisé une
grande variété de chars en france en
1940 le char léger vickers marque 6
le transporteur brendan les chars
d'infanterie mark 1 et 2 et bien sûr les
mathilde à 1 et mathilda 2 il y avait
aussi les cruisers tank comme le cruiser
marque un monte sur une suspension des
curse et le cruiser marcq cap sur une
suspension christie's mécaniquement
c'était un char très important pour les
anglais il disposait d'une suspension
américaine conçue par un inventeur
indépendant nommé jim holt heures
christine christie commencé à dessiner
des chars au milieu des années 20
et en 1928 il produisit un char aux
performances impressionnantes en 1932 un
de ses chars avait atteint 100 km/heure
sur ces feux ni et en enlevant ses
chenilles et en le faisant rouler
normalement
il avait atteint 1 192 km heure comme
sorte de charme boxster si vous préférez
christie était un drôle d'individu qui
s'était brouillé avec tout le monde dans
l'administration us si bien que les
américains avaient construit six de ses
chars avant d'abandonner les russes
avaient acheté le char de christie
trouvant qu'il représentait tout ce dont
ils avaient besoin en termes de
mécanique il avait copié à des milliers
d'exemplaires
ce furent deux officiers anglais qui
visitent en l'armée rouge en manoeuvre
vers 1935 avait vu ses tanks et
revinrent d'impressionner charger leurs
notes field le chef de maurice motors
d'acheter un char christie à partir
duquel il pourrait développer leur
propre système est finalement le seul
truc qui l'ont gardé de christie étaient
la suspension et saclay qui est
constitué de larges roues à grand
diamètre et d'un système interne
formidable qui laissait une grande
liberté de mouvement vous ne trouverez
aucun char nulle part avec un tel espace
entre les chenilles et la timonerie pour
permettre aux ou de bouger cela signifie
que vous pouvez atteindre des vitesses
terrible mais aller au delà de 100
kilomètres/heure serait ridicule car
très dangereux en revanche ce char
pouvait rouler à 50 km/heure en douceur
ceci donnait à l'équipage un certain
confort ce qui est important en raison
de la manière britannique d'envisager
les choses
nous croyons que les équipages de chars
devait tirer en roulant contre des
cibles mobiles et atteindre une
efficacité absolument exceptionnel pour
l'époque mais souvenez vous qu'il s'agit
d'une armée peut entraîner et non de
professionnels très motivés le résultat
donne l'a13 cruiser le canon à une
élévation sans limite
ce qui signifie que le canonnier devait
le stabiliser en se tenant dans une
position semi accroupi à l'intérieur de
la tourelle
une main sur la détente du canon l'oeil
sur le télescope son autre main sur le
mécanisme et ses genoux essayant de
stabiliser le canon vous pouvez imaginer
la difficulté
un soldat bien m'entraîner pour être
embarqué sur le char bien entraîné a new
world pour toucher une cible mobile en
roulant avait un coût plus élevé que le
soldat tout juste sortis des réserves
territoriales comme soldats et que vous
n'arrivez pas à entraîner assez
rapidement pour le mettre aux standards
dans le temps imparti le à 9m qu'à un
cruiser peser 13 tonnes et son équipage
était de six hommes la puissance de feu
était celle d'un canon de deux livres
mais cette fois épaulé par trois
mitrailleuses vickers
il était peu blindé avec seulement 14 mm
d'épaisseur mais avec une vitesse de
pointe de 40 km heure comme pour le
cruiser marque 4-1 le design comportait
de nombreux angles dans lesquelles se
fichait les obus perforant ennemis le
résultat fut qu'un grand nombre fut
détruit pendant la campagne de france le
char à neuf par bien des aspects montrer
l'état désolant des blindés anglais
pendant l'entre-deux-guerres
bon ce n'était pas parce que les anglais
ne pouvais pas concevoir de bons chars
vous mais c'était surtout parce que le
budget de l'armée étaient restreints
c'était le troisième des il arrivait
après celui de l'aviation et de la
marine bleue à 9 fut conçu avec un tout
petit budget ça signifie que ni son
blindage ni son moteur n'était capable
de remplir les fonctions qu'on lui
demandait de plus il n'était pas assez
blindé ni même assez armé pour jouer son
rôle avec l'infanterie il n'était pas
d'une conception très valables et ne fut
pas d'une grande efficacité au combat
il est l'exemple même d'une conception
de transition née d'une réflexion
android pour commencer le pire de tout
ce sont ces petites tourelles en plus de
la toile principal équipé du canon de 40
mm et sa mitrailleuse d'appui il y a
donc deux autres petites tourelles de
chaque côté du poste de conduite et
chacune est équipée d'une mitrailleuse
vickers on trouve des tourelles de cette
sorte sur certains chars de la fin des
années 20 qui avait posé pas mal de
problèmes entre autres parce qu'il n'y a
pas beaucoup de place dedans
l'autre problème principal avec la
tourelle c'est qu'on ne peut pas
augmenter l'épaisseur de blindage
car avec la manière dont ces tourelles
sont montés de chaque côté du conducteur
toute augmentation d'épaisseur ne leur
laissait pas la possibilité de rester
mobile donc les 14 mm initiaux c'est
tout ce sur quoi vous pouvez compter
l'autre problème c'est cet équipage de
six hommes trois dans la toile principal
le conducteur dans la cabine ici et deux
dans les autres touraine
la france a été très influente dans la
conception de nouvelles machines comme
les anglais il avait quatre modèles
principaux disponible au début de la
campagne de france
les chars français
le char se mue en f 35 était un char
moyen de 20 tonnes avec trois hommes à
bord
il était armé d'un canon de 47 mm et
d'une mitrailleuse de 7,5 un blindage
assez épais de 55 mm et une vitesse de
40 km heure ce char était capable de
faire mal à l'ennemi et était bien conçu
la preuve en est que les allemands
l'intégrer dans leurs forces blindées
après l'armistice de 1940 tech 5
c'est un char conçu pour affronter
d'autres chatte en conséquence une
attention toute particulière a été
portée à son blindage et ses capacités
de combat mais malheureusement les deux
chars le show muas et le char b1 avait
la même tour elle donc vous aviez les
mêmes problèmes c'est à dire que vous
aviez un homme dans la tourelle en plus
du chef de chats dont la fonction était
de s'occuper du canon principal et de la
mitrailleuse l'autre formidable
innovation du chemin a été son blindage
moulé c'est une des caractéristiques qui
influencèrent les ingénieurs américains
lors de la mise en chantier du sherman
qui adoptait un blindage moulés dans
plusieurs versions sur le plan mécanique
comme d'autres chars français il était
impeccable le système de suspension
était vraiment compliqué et vous
remarquerez que les français rencontré
beaucoup de difficultés pour masquer
cette suspension
quelque chose qu'on ne reverra plus
pendant la guerre mais il l'a protégé
pour l'empêcher d'être endommagés bien
des points en dehors de ses capacités au
combat c'était un prénom chars pour
l'époque
le char b1 et est le plus lourd avec 32
tonnes et un équipage de quatre hommes
il avait un canon de 75 sur le châssis
et un de 47 mm dans la tourelle en plus
ils avaient deux mitrailleuses de 7,5 mm
à bord le blindage de 60 mm étaient très
bons la vitesse était limitée à 25 km
heure car le poids était un facteur
important
c'était un très bon chars et qui donna
le meilleur pendant les combats contre
les allemands les principales
restrictions était que le canon de 75 du
châssis ne pouvait tirer que droit
devant en plus bien que le blindage
était bon les allemands découvrir qu'il
était possible de le mettre hors de
combat en tirant dans la grille de
ventilation
cependant au début de la campagne de
france il était sans doute le meilleur
char en service avant la guerre il était
déjà considéré comme l'un des meilleurs
chars au monde mais il y avait une ou
deux caractéristiques qui ressortait en
premier lieu l'armement principal de 75
mm a été placé dans le châssis à côté du
conducteur
bien qu'il puisse être mobile vers le
haut et vers le bas il ne pouvait
effectuer aucun mouvement latéral chaque
millimètre ou degré de mouvement latéral
était banques effectués en bougeant tout
le chat afin que le canon puisse être
dirigé vers sa cible et non ceux ci
n'était pas une très bonne idée sur le
plan tactique car d'avoir à bouger
exiger un système de pilotage très
sophistiqué ce char avait un système
hydrostatique de conduite qui permettait
de bouger le char au degré près mais le
conducteur était impliqué dans la visée
ce qui n'était pas le cas pour la
tourelle les français étaient assez
logique
et puisque le pilote était impliqué dans
la visée ils pouvaient aussi s'occuper
de l'élévation du canon donc le
conducteur utilisé sa main droite sur
une petite route manuel pour monter ou
descendre le canon ils ont poussé cette
logique jusqu'à son terme
il est on dit puisqu'il fait la visée
autant qu'il puisse déclencher aussi le
tir donc c'était le rôle du conducteur
d'élever le canon et de tirer c'est la
raison pour laquelle les instruments de
visée était dans le viseur du conducteur
et ça devait occuper pas mal
il avait un chargeur qui travaillent est
derrière lui et à l'arrière du char se
trouve l opérateur radio
le gars dans la tourelle était le chef
du chat son rôle était de commander le
temps qui est de distribuer les ordres à
l'équipage
ils devaient relayer les messages radio
de l'opérateur s'occuper de viser avec
le canon antichar chargé et tirer avec
la mitrailleuse la désennuyer car il
avait une fâcheuse tendance à s'enrayer
en résumé en termes d'ergonomie se
blinder ne semblait pas l'idéal il est
très intéressant de constater si on
étudie les journaux de marche des
allemands qui ont combattu en france
lorsqu'ils ont rencontré ses blindés et
ils se sont demandé s'il n'allait pas
avoir besoin de chars plus gros sur le
champ de bataille racontent qu'ils
arrivaient cependant approché très près
des chars français avant d'être
remarquée la raison en est est clair
c'est que à bord tout le monde était
très occupé il n'avait pas le temps de
surveiller ce qui se passait à
l'extérieur
je pense aussi que la vision vers
l'extérieur laissait vraiment à désirer
le hotchkiss h35 b était l'un des deux
chars légers en service en france
il pesait 12 tonnes et avait un équipage
de deux hommes comme la plupart des
chars français les allemands affirment
important usage après leur victoire
le renault r30 5 était un autre char
léger mais sa vitesse n'était que de 20
km heure
les charrs alliés en particulier les
chars français surpassaient les tanks
allemands en terme de protection et
d'armement les allemands furent surpris
de voir leurs canons antichars de 37 mm
être inefficace contre les blindages de
ces chars
la faiblesse des charges alliés fut en
réalité la manière dont ils furent
utilisés enfin les chars français
étaient meilleurs que les nôtres et ceux
des allemands mais ils étaient
éparpillés sur toute la longueur de la
frontière française
lorsque les allemands attaquèrent ceux
de chars étaient disponibles pour les
contrer et grâce à leur tactique bien en
place ils passèrent le haut-commandement
utilise à ces forces blindées en soutien
de ses unités d'infanterie et
l'essentiel des pertes des chars
français fut causée par des attaques de
ce tout cas des tirs d'artillerie des
mines ou des canons antichars
c'était principalement parce que les
chars allemands étaient eux à la pointe
de l'attaqué foncé vers la côte des
chars français furent utilisés pour
attaquer les flancs de la taca demande
leurs opposants étaient des véhicules
non blindés ou des canons antichars
la campagne avait été baptisée opération
jaune le plan avait été conçu par von
manstein mais avait été créditée par
hitler c'est une variation du plan
schlieffen de la première guerre
mondiale le planchot l'iphone avait pour
objectif de pousser les alliés à travers
les pays bas
le mouvement devait être suivie par une
vague d'attaqués à travers la zone
alliés en passant par paris pour les
encercler définitivement le plan avait
échoué en 14 18
mais les allemands était confiant en la
victoire cette fois ci toutefois les
plans de l'opération yellow était tombée
aux mains des alliés à la suite d'un
accident d'avion
cela signifiait que les allemands
devaient revoir leur plan d'attaqué
cette fois manstein envisage à une fois
encore une attaque puissante à travers
les pays bas comme dans le plan
d'origine
le principal changement était la
direction de la poussée initiale elle
serait fait à travers les ardennes
compense est impraticable pour les
blindés pour cette attaque
les allemands séparèrent leurs troupes
en trois groupes d'armées le groupe
d'armées b devait avancer à travers la
hollande et la belgique
servant ainsi d'appât pour les troupes
alliées le groupe d'armées à aller
passer à travers les ardennes et être la
force de frappe principal le groupe
d'armées c'est serait envoyé face à la
ligne maginot afin d'occuper les
défenseurs français
la poussée principal avait pour objectif
de foncer à travers les positions
ennemies et de filer vers la côte
française vers boulogne et calais les
alliés avaient anticipé la répétition
des événements de la première guerre
mondiale et placer leurs troupes en
conséquence le gros des forces étaient
positionnés au nord près pour l'attack à
travers les pays bas il y avait deux
lignes de réserve
une d'elles était positionné dans les
ardennes les alliés avaient
grossièrement surestimé les forces
blindées des allemands pensant qu'ils
avaient plus de 7000 chars la vérité
était que les allemands avaient juste
2400 chars pour l'attack essentiellement
des panzers mais plus de 1400 d'entre
eux n'étaient rien d'autre que des
automitrailleuses blindés les alliés
avaient plus de 3300 char sur le plan de
l'armement et du blindage les machines
alliés étaient supérieurs aux chars
allemands
lorsque la tacc commença aux premières
heures du dimanche elle prie les alliés
par surprise les allemands avancer très
vite les alliés avaient favorisé cette
progression fulgurante en positionnant
leur force plus au nord alors que le
gros des troupes allemandes passer par
les ardennes un peu plus au sud les
alliés avaient été bercé dans un faux
sentiment de sécurité et pensait qu'ils
étaient capables de détruire les forces
allemandes
bien que ceux ci aient des lacunes en
termes d'armement il avait été très bien
entraînés et avait rôdé la coordination
de leurs forces
le concept était simple mais très
efficace est en avance sur son temps
le point d'impact choisi était petit en
termes de largeur
les blindés se concentrèrent sur ce
point central et toute la puissance de
feu étaient utilisés pour écraser
l'ennemi
une fois la brèche percée le reste de la
division devait se ruer à travers le
trou et foncer vers les zones arrière de
l'ennemi les tanks devait continuer à
foncer à travers les lignes ennemies
jusqu'à ce que l'infanterie et
l'artillerie puisse s'occuper des poches
de résistance et capturer les positions
clés les artilleurs antichar devait
établir un écran de protection pour
protéger les zones déjà capturé
face à des attaques parfaitement
coordonné les alliés furent plongés dans
la confusion et la panique
il pensait toujours à la dernière guerre
et s'était préparé à une bataille
défensive
les allemands avaient prouvé qu'une
rapide et profonde percée à travers les
lignes ennemies était une excellente
manière de se défendre
on a vu les chars allemands descendre la
route
alors on a commencé à reculer on savait
où on allait
mais on y allait loin des allemands qui
nous précède nous avons fait des
kilomètres chaque jour rattrapant les
troupes anglaises les troupes anglaises
qui battait en retraite
aucun doute on fuyait les civils
français encombrer les routes et nous
cracher dessus en criant salle rosbif
l'avancent la plus remarquable fut celle
de la 7e division de panzers commandée
par le général erwin rommel sa force
blindés avancent et rapidement à travers
les zones mal défendu de la belgique
lorsqu'ils arrivèrent dans les zones
bien défendu en france ils utilisèrent
leur vitesse la surprise et leur
puissance de feu pour balayer l'ennemi
son unité fut la première à traverser la
meuse une fois de l'autre côté ils font
ces revers arras
la 7e division de panzers avancer si
vite qu'elle reçut la dénomination nom
officiel de division fantôme en avançant
plus loin ils arrivèrent dans une zone
tenue par un mélange de troupes
françaises et anglaises
les anglais plus honneur de la vence
allemande décidèrent de monter une
contre-offensive dans la direction
d'arras
il avait l'impression que les français
plus au sud à l'est aussi attaqué le 21
mai les anglais lancèrent leur attaque
contre les flancs allemand wanted ce fut
monté par une très petite force de 60
chars d'infanterie britannique et une
brigade d'infanterie
acronis tout cas bombarder sans cesse il
fut retardé ce qui signifiait que les
chars mathilde à 1 et 2 foncer vers la
7e division de romell quasiment sans
soutien les allemands furent stupéfaits
que leurs tirs anti char de 37 mm
rebondi simplement contre les chars
anglais ceux ci furent capables de
progresser vers arras écrasant les
canons antichars sous leurs chenilles et
détruisant bon nombre de blindés et le
véhicule de rebelles menacent qu'ils ont
constituée en fonçant à travers la
campagne en deux colonnes et en
attaquant la colonne allemande ainsi
tard mais lui-même a quitté ses
positions avec ses chars et a reculé car
ils se trouvaient isolés en france avec
les anglais et parfois même les français
à ses trousses il se trouvait face à un
problème sérieux
il rassembla donc tous les cas non
disponibles dans la zone des canons
antiaériens de 88 mm jusqu aux canons
d'artillerie aux armes anti-char il
stoppa l'attaquant de blaise dans un
dernier effort avec des armes dont ce
n'était pas toujours la fonction mais
qui pendant quelques heures
ur leur moment de gloire
les allemands avaient estimé les forces
alliées à plusieurs centaines de blindés
mais de fait il y en avait beaucoup
moins bien que l'attaqué a été menée
avec détermination elle ne pouvait
stopper l'avancée lui mais elle fut
sanglante pour les allemands elle
montrait aussi la menace qu aurait pu
représenter les alliés s'il avait été
mieux organisés et mieux diriger
quelques jours avant cette attaque
les allemands avaient atteint la cote
toute l'organisation alliés avaient été
balayés les troupes du reich était à
deux doigts de battre totalement leurs
ennemis en conclusion d'une campagne
stupéfiante
il avait complètement encerclé les
alliés à dunkerque
c'est alors qu'hitler leur ordonna de
stopper leur progression et une grande
partie des forces alliées réussit alors
à s'échapper vers l'angleterre
lorsque la zone fut abandonné les
allemands firent le tour du chaos que
les alliés avaient laissé derrière eux
il avait été forcé de tout abandonner et
la majorité de leur matériel était en
ruines autour du port mais la victoire
des allemands n'étaient pas encore
complète
la phase suivante exigeait qu'ils se
dirigent vers le sud et se concentre sur
les forces françaises et britanniques
qui reste est soit 66 division et quand
un truc car on était dans les docks et
les messerschmidt nous mitraille est il
y avait beaucoup de navires
ils mitraillaient dégâts sur les bateaux
et bien sûr un grand nombre de nos
copains ont été tuées quand nous sommes
montés sur le bateau
nous avons eu la chance d'être sur un
gros on a vu le messerschmitt piqué
largué sa bombe sur le gros paquebot
c'était le lancaster
il ya eu beaucoup de soldats tués
cette nouvelle offensive comment ça le 5
juin 1940
moins de trois semaines plus tard les
alliés étaient complètement battu
l'armistice fut signé c'était une fin
idéale et une victoire complète pour
hitler et sa nouvelle arme blindés la
victoire allemande spectaculaire et est
une belle illustration du concept de
guerre éclair
la part joué par les chars allemands
avait été crucial en six semaines il
avait détruit les armes et hollandaises
belges françaises et anglaises la
confiance des allemands était à son
paroxysme
il avait totalement confiance en leurs
soldats et en leur matériel en
particulier en leur char qui avait
grandement participé à la victoire
finale la plus rapprochée apportée par
la luftwaffe avait été aussi un facteur
décisif en terrorisant les soldats
adverses
hitler considéré naguère comme gagnait
le développement de nouvelles armes fut
freiné afin que l'effort industriel soit
affectée au développement d'armes
antichars et de fusils d'assaut peu
coûteux les déficiences qui était apparu
en termes de blindage et d'armement
refirent surface dans les campagnes
suivantes est sûrs de graves
conséquences
l'idée de l'invincibilité s'étaient
inscrites dans tous les esprits
hitler était déjà en train de penser à
ce qui serait son plus gros pari et
l'équipement des forces armées ne subit
pas de remaniement sérieux après la
campagne de france hitler démobilise à
certaines sections de l'armée allemande
qui vous il ne s'intéressait pas au
renforcement de ses divisions blindées
il ne fit aucun effort pour conçoivent
de nouveaux véhicules blindés ou de
nouveaux chars et ses fameuses ordre de
fin 1940 furent des conséquences
néfastes surtout le développement
technique qui avait exigé plus d'une
année pour être menée en interne et qui
allait être du coup en retard pour la
campagne suivante
l'opération barbarossa l'invasion de la
russie adolf hitler se plongea dans la
planification de l'invasion de la
puissante union soviétique
il était confiant ses armées qui il en
était sur lui apporterait la victoire
une fois de plus les hommes au front à
la vie de découvrir à quel point leur
char allait être inefficace contre les
forces armées ennemies